foreign
[Music]
I was thinking tonight could be a good
night for sex night possibly
interesting idea but you know Thursdays
Stephen London how's the new Opera
coming along good great great we had
discussed seeing a first draft of the
score in two weeks is that still all
right I'm suffering from a temporary
blockage at the moment
no turn it back on
good
fat
is he all right he had a total breakdown
after his last opera
I can't do this
we need to take a walk jolt your brain
out of its little rad pattern interact
with a stranger okay honey I have a
patient
are we going that way I keep imagining
you naked I don't know if you want to
hear more details about these images no
[Music]
about every one of these people has a
story for an opera in them Levi what do
you do I operated Tempo the wrong hands
this tug is a deadly weapon
foreign
I've been arrested for stalking I had to
go to rehab and I'm not supposed to be
doing this
can't believe that actually happened I
mean she seduced me right she's a witch
the demented tugboat captain who knows
men to her Tugboat and kills them
beneath them I've loved it how did you
come up with that
I was really angry at you and now it
turns out I'm your Muse oh Steve I'll
never leave you
um I love cleaning cleanliness is close
to government where my patients are
talking I imagine getting inside their
heads with disinfectant and just
scrubbing them down
your tugboat captain came to see me I'm
in Love no no just admit that I had a
magic effect on you my imagination came
up with the story my talent wrote the
music I mean you don't kill men and eat
them do you no I haven't yet
I know I can't resist a romantic story
even if I'm not in it
[Music]